nick thomas simmons you never stop
criticizing the government
for their failures what objection could
you possibly have
to an effort to make the removal of
foreign
national offenders quicker and more
effective
well clearly uh people who've no right
to be
in this country shouldn't be here but
what we've seen
from the home office is utter
incompetence on this and let me just
take
an example as well we talk about the
asylum system the government keeps
saying the asylum system
is broken they've been in power for 11
years and they
broke it if you look at 2014 87
of asylum claims are being dealt with
within six months
that figure had fallen to 20 percent by
2019 and what did the government do
they got rid of performance targets and
what we
don't want to see is the government
deflecting blame
for their own failure and it is their
compete in confidence
their management and mismanagement of
the home office that's been the problem
so so let's so labour's solution to
people coming ashore
uh on the beaches of kent is that uh
there should be performance tag target
for civil servants
there should be uh performance targets
in the asylum system but in terms of
the issue of both
in terms of the english channel in my
view the government
needs to look at a number of measures
firstly
the long promised agreement with france
that needs to be effective it needs to
be fully published made available to us
all
that's first and that's a priority for
the government
secondly the government needs to revisit
its decision to abolish the department
for international development the very
department that existed
to prevent people being driven from
their homes in the first place the very
department
department was trying to deal with you
know the the issues that come from war
poverty and persecution thirdly the
government needs to look at the issue of
safe routes for example
they close down the dub scheme the dub
scheme which
everyone in parliament expected expected
to
take in 3 000 unaccompanied child
refugees was closed down prematurely
after 300.
that's the kind of approach the
government needs to be taken because
none of us want to see people making
these dangerous crossings across the
channel
okay let's let's let's deal with a real
world situation
i asked the home secretary about the two
men in glasgow and she's pretty clear
um you know she's pretty hard line on
this they're going they're going to go
what would labour do look
as a general principle people who
shouldn't be
in this country people who shouldn't be
here absolutely yes they have to be
removed with this particular situation
in glasgow
i don't know in terms of the particular
circumstances of it i'm not sure the due
process
has been observed the home office
doesn't have a great track record on
that i'm afraid i think something like
55 percent of a cl
asylum claims succeed on appeal so i
think there has to be that guarantee on
due process and second
the whole method of immigration
enforcement
by the use of dawn raids is something
the government has to seriously
reconsider
because that particular method of
enforcement isn't something
clearly that is building the confidence
right across the community that we need
to
with respect mr thomas what you're
telling me is why
everybody why the government isn't doing
its job what i'd like to know is
what would you do if it is demonstrated
that these
gentlemen should be removed because they
have overstayed
would you as she has promised to do be
sending
the immigration enforcement people back
in
if if it is shown the due process has
been
fully followed and people aren't
entitled to stay whether it's the
two men in glasgow indeed anywhere else
then yes of course they should be
removed but the point i'm making trevor
around enforcement
is that the particular method of
enforcement that's being used here which
is this sort of
dawn raid system that's being used is
not a method of enforcement that is
gaining
any kind of confidence from the
community there are better ways of doing
things
but people who are not entitled to be
here yes they should be removed
okay um big story today the bbc
what do you think that the bbc the
national broadcaster
has to do to restore the public's trust
and in particular the public who fund it
well fundamentally the bbc now needs to
show
that what happened with the martin
bashir
interview couldn't happen again that
obtaining of an interview
by deception and we've seen the the
impact
that's had on the royal family have you
heard princess william and harry talk
very
movingly about the impact that that has
had and then very understandably now
that's raised very wide
questions about ethics and about how
that can be prevented from happening
again i think there's a specific
question too
as to how the bbc came to once again
employing mr bashir in 2016 and how that
happened
but look the bbc makes some some great
programs
the bbc still has a great reputation
around the world but it now has to
rebuild
trust and prove to people that what
happened
then couldn't happen again now
but do you think you know making
strictly and attenborough documentaries
makes up for
lying to princess diana do you think
that the bbc has run out of road and
that
now now it can't continue marking its
own homework which is really the
question today
well look certainly making great
programs certainly doesn't
make up in any sense for what's happened
here what's happened here
certainly has to be dealt with now there
has been
a change in governance structure since
back then in those days of course you
had the board of governors who
you know were guarded as of course too
close to the management at the time and
there is this
different structure that it exists now
uh there is of course that but what we
need to see from the bbc now is quite
openly to tell us
what it is in the structure that now
exists that's different that would stop
that from happening and what they're
going to do now
to rebuild that trust thank you very
much dick thomas simmons from
cardiff